it was something of a nightmare an
inferno in the early hours Flames
engulfing this Perth Hotel
hours later the charred remains told a
Grimm's story confirming the fears of a
community in shock
I can confirm that three people have
sadly died at the scene
a number of Hotel guests and two people
from a neighboring block of flats were
evacuated and are being supported by
partner agencies at this time 11 people
were treated for minor injuries amid
Ablaze which was extinguished in less
than two hours
our firefighters work extremely hard in
a very complex and challenging
environment
to prevent the further spread of fire
and damage where possible speaking
exclusively to Sky News one hotel
resident told of the horror of running
for her life as we reach the front door
she said you could see burning embers
falling to the ground we ran through as
quickly as we could hoping that nothing
would fall on us she continued we didn't
realize how close we were to where the
fire started really we're lucky to get
out alive
absolutely tragic three people have lost
their lives we don't know who they are
yet but they may well have been visited
to Perth come to visit Perth over the
Christmas and holiday period and
unfortunately won't be going home and we
have to think about their families this
is the scene of a painstaking operation
a joint investigation now underway by
both the police and the fire service to
preserve the scene here and determine
the cause as a community Waits For
answers
the families of those killed also now
mourning the loss of their loved ones as
many here now begin to question how this
tragedy unfolded Conor Gillis Sky News
Perth